Hong Kong is bracing for more disorder
on Monday as some pro-democracy
protesters call for a general strike
police been trying to control small
groups of protesters who tried to
disrupt the metro system during rush
hour at least one arrest has been made
over the weekend we there were brutal
scenes of police violence following
chaotic protests passengers filmed
police storming a train compartment
beating passengers and using pepper
spray well for the very latest let's
cross over to Hong Kong where DW
Charlotte chousen pill is standing by
Charlotte schools and universities are
returning to session in Hong Kong today
what's the situation like that this was
meant to be the first day back for so
many students across Hong Kong today but
rather than just a normal first day this
will certainly be one that they'll
remember for a very long time I'm at an
assembly here at the moment where a
number of students who are taking part
in that strike gathered I'm sure you can
see a number of them behind me dressed
in their school uniform still many of
them were there their faces covered
feared afraid of being identified there
are so many repercussions for people
taking part in protests here that that
people just don't want their faces shown
now alongside this rally there is also a
rally happening at a university
university students on strike as well as
the general strike employees not going
to work either as you mentioned people
tried to disrupt the travel service
again this morning tried to stop trains
there was a very heavy police presence
on the platforms to try and prevent that
and it allowed today to run as smoothly
as possible clearly the idea today is to
cause as much disruption as possible
presumably Charlotte some of those
students will want to get on with their
studies with many of them back at school
could the protest movement lose some of
its momentum now oh yes to be clear it's
not all students who are participating
in this strike as for whether or not it
will lose momentum now the schools about
well there's a couple of factors there
first of all it's not clear whether or
not that this is going to be a one-off
event this
does continue tomorrow as well there has
been some discussion as well about
whether or not they should make it a a
weekly thing every Monday these students
are not returning to school but one big
discussion point here at the moment is
what would happen among those students
who are back at school who have been
taking part in these protests a week
after week as we know very young people
have been on the streets some of them on
the front line some indeed of school age
have been arrested there's this concern
about what happens when you mix these
students who are who are pro-democracy
supporters and those who haven't been
taken to the streets will there be
bullying what happens to the children of
police officers who the target of so
much anger here amongst this
pro-democracy movement but to be clear
so much of this violence takes place on
the weekends so these students will
still be able to take to the streets
this weekend once again should they
choose to well we saw scenes of police
brutality over this past weekend how are
people in Hong Kong reacting to that
there is an awful lot of anger among
pro-democracy supporters about what
unfolded on Saturday we saw there's
really dramatic images of police
entering train carriage using battens
against passengers it wasn't clear even
whether or not they've been taking part
in the protest that day or whether or
not they were just caught up in the
violence now rather than have that put
people off the fear of over being hurt
and of course the very real fear of
being arrested instead it seems to be
fueling this movement even more people
so angry emboldened even to take to the
streets to fight for what they say is
the encroachment of Beijing on their
riots here in Hong Kong and anger
against the police that what they say is
their mishandling of this entire 13 week
protest movement Charlotte thanks for
bringing us up-to-date DW Charlotte
Chelse until they're in Hong Kong